الابتسامه كلمه طيبه بدون ولا حرف هل
اعتقدت يوما عن الابتسامه يمكن ان تنسى ان
تفقد من الذاكره تحاول من جديد ان تتعلم
عليها بل وتتدرب على استعداد استخدامها
هذا ما ال اليه الحال في اليابان ارتداء
الكمامات لمده ثلاثه اعوام اثر سلبا على
ابتسامه الشعب الياباني المحب
للابتسام لهذه العاده طبعا الكثيرون من قد
نسوا بالفعل كيفيه الابتسام بحسب موقع
لذلك لجا العديد من اليابانيين الى التدرب
من جديد على تطويع تعابير وجههم مستعينين
بما اطلق عليهم او اطلق عليهم المعلمون
المبتسمون عدد المتقدمين للتدرب على
الابتسامه دون ان تنتابهم مشاعر الحرج
ارتفع بمقدار 4.5 بعد ان اعلنت الحكومه
اليابانيه انها
تنهي توصياتها بضروره ارتداء الكمامات وهي
المضاده لفيروس كورونا طبعا المدربون على
فن الابتسامه يقولون ان الامر ببساطه يشبه
تدريب اجزاء او عضلات اخرى من الجسم بما
الوجه كل عضلات وبالتالي فانه عضلات الوجه
بحاجه الى التدريب ايضا والسؤال من زاويه
مختلفه هل التدرب على الابتسامه قد يكون
فيه نوع من التصنع
وما اثرها على سعادتنا حقا على كل حال
الاجابه في دراسه مع الزميله لميس صيدليه
لميس شكرا لكم واكيد الابتسامه من القلب
اذا بدي اشوفكم من القلب الى القلب
الابتسامه تعد مفتاح العلاقات الانسانيه
واقرب الطرق للقلوب ولكن ماذا ان كانت هذه
الابتسامه مزيفه هل يجعلنا تصنع الابتسامه
اسعد في دراسه نشرت في
طلب من حوالي 3800 متطوع من تسعه عشره
دوله ان يبتسموا حتى يحافظ على تعابير
محايد باستخدام عده دوافع مختلفه ثم تقييم
سعادتهم الدراسه اظهرت ان الابتسام كان له
تاثير على السعاده اكثر من الانشطه
البسيطه الاخرى التي تنطوي على حركات
العضلات واشارت النتائج الى ان ردود الفعل
على الوجه لا يمكنها فقط تضخيم الشعور
المستمر بالسعاده وايضا تثير مشاعر
السعاده نفسها وكتب الباحثون ان تزييف
الابتسامه يمكن ان يؤثر على مزاجنا لان
الناس يستنتجون انهم سعداء لانهم يبتسمون
كما ان الابتسام ينشط تلقائيا العمليات
البيولوجيه المرتبطه بالعاطفه
[موسيقى]
شوفي ابتسامه الضيف
طيب يلا الان برايك سالنا الناس برايك هل
الابتسامه فن يحتاج الى التدريب شوف شو
اللي قالوا
[موسيقى]
لا
انها من رب العالمين
ابتسامه حسب نفسيه البني ادم
لازم يكون الانسان مبتسم حتى لو ايش ما
كان يعني الابتسامه لازم تكون مش لازم
تكون انه الانسان من طبيعته مبتسم لان
حديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم تبسمك
فيها وجه اخيك صدقه فلو مبتسم البشوش هو
من اجمل الوجوه لابتسامه بتيجي مع الانسان
من داخله الانسان المبتسم الضحوك دائما
انسان مبشر دائما يكون في الخير وفي كل
شيء
لا يحتاج انها تكون فن او تدريب
[موسيقى]
يعني اكيد لا لانه الابتسامه ربانيه
والابتسامه اكيد لازم تكون موجوده على كل
بني ادم الابتسامه زي ما قال الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم لاخيك صدقه هذه ما بدا
تدريب ولا بدها
انك تقعد تمارس عليها لا ابدا الابتسامه
بتطلع من القلب وبتدل على ايجابيه الشخص
ويعني سعد سعادته بالحياه فما بحسها هي
بدها تدريب قد ما هي بس بدها مجهود صغير
لحتى تطلع الابتسامه للعالم يعني بالنسبه
الي الابتسامه كل شيء يعني مرات بدك تتدرب
على الابتسامه لانه ما بتعرف متى بتكون
مضطرت تبتسم بوجه حدا محتاج هاي الابتسامه
فقه وبنفس الوقت تتدرب عليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا من الرياضه الاستشاري النفسيه
الدكتور اسامه النعيمي صباح الخير يا
دكتور منورنا في صباح العربيه هذا الصباح
صبحك الله بالخير راويه صباح الخير عادل
تدرب على المشاهدين المستمعين المتصفحين
صباح الخير على اولادنا الثلاثه اللي
موجودين في الفضاء الله
كل التوفيق لهم اكيد يعني طيب دكتور
وابتسامتك منوره على الصباح هل ممكن خلينا
ندخل الموضوع على طول هل عنجد ممكن ننسى
كيف نبتسم يعني حتى بفتره كورونا مع كل
القيود مع عدم التعامل مع الحجر عدم
التعامل مع الناس الاخرين ومن تحت الكمامه
كنا نبتسم حتى لما العيون تظهر طاقه بالف
عل التقرير اللي عرضتوه يتحدث عن نوع واحد
من الابتسامه اللي هي الابتسامه العفويه
ويتحدث عن شكل واحد من الابتسامه اللي هي
ابتسامه السعاده بينما في 25 نوع على
الاقل من الابتسامات اللي هي بعض الاحيان
ما تكون عفويه التدريب اللي صار في
اليابان لم يكن على الابتسامه العفويه لان
الابتسامه العفويه مثل ما قال تقريركم لا
يحتاج نهائيا الى محفز هي تصدر من القلب
وهي دليل على الشعور بالسعاده او الرضا
بينما بعض الابتسامات قد ما تكون هذا
الشيء بعض ابتسامات قد تكون دليل على
الاسى والالم او الغضب او التحكم او حتى
الاغراء فهذه الابتسامات هي اللي تحتاج
تدريب وهذا الابتسامات اللي الان المجتمع
الياباني المعروف بانه مبتسم دائما ليس
لانه سعيد بس مبتسم لنا جزء من الثقافه
المجتمعيه يحتاج تدريب مره اخرى يعني
دائما ما يقال بانه الوجه وعضلات الوجه
اذا تدربت على الابتسامه الابتسامه
صنعت تعب العضلات يا دكتور كيف يمكن لنا
ان نتعلم على هذا الابتسام وكيف لنا ان
ننسى يعني هي مده عضلات
بس مو هي هي مش بس العضلات اللي موجوده هي
الموقف اللي انت موجود في شكل العضله
نفسها حركه العين حركه الاكتاف ثم ماذا
نقدمه للطرف الاخر عند الابتسامه فاذا انت
كنت مبتسم عفوا لم اقصد انت عادي احدهم
عندما وجد عندما وجد انه شخص يطيح ويتعور
هذا لا تعتبر سعاده انما هذا تعتبر تهكم
وانتقاص بالاخر ولا اتوقع من الاخر ان
يبادلني الابتسامه وانا ابتسم من المه
لذلك لما كانت تهدى الابتسامه كانت تهدى
بدون مقابل وبدون انه يكون الموقف الاخر
مؤلم للطرف الاخر كانت تهدى لانها الطرف
الاخر بحاجه لها مش لانه احنا مجبرين
عليها وارجع اقول انه ما حدث في اليابان
لا يعتبر قاعدهم لم ينسوا الابتسامه هم
نسوا فن الابتسامه المجتمعيه التي يعرفها
اليابانيين واترك لليابانيين ان يحولوا
المشاعر الحلوه الى تدريب وقوانين وسواليف
عجيبه غريبه
عم نبتسم هل حتى لو ما كانت الابتسامه
نابعه من القلب اذا دربنا نفسنا على كثر
الابتسام دائما هل هذا اشي ممكن يحسن من
مزاجنا ويحسن من حالتنا نفسيه
الغريب انه الجواب نعم في الحالتين اذا
كانت الابتسامه حقيقيه او اقل صدقيه الى
حد ما ترفع مستوى السعاده عندنا وتشعرنا
بالرضا عن انفسنا حتى لو كان لفتره بسيطه
ان لم تكن الابتسامه حقيقيه لكن انظري الى
الموقف لما لما الام ترى الابتسامه على
وجه الرضيع هي نفسها تشعر بالسعاده وتشعر
بالرضا عن ذاته ويرتفع عندها هرمون
السعاده لانها تشعر انه هي اخذت ابتسامه
عفويه اذا الطرفين يشعرون بالسعاده اذا
كانت الابتسامه حقيقيه لكن الى حد كبير
الشخص الذي حتى وان كان يمثل الابتسامه
الى فتره بسيطه يشعر بالرضا عن نفسه دائما
ابتسموه اي والله دكتور يعني يعطيك
العافيه شكرا جزيلا الدكتور النفسي اسامه
النعيمي الاستشاري النفسي انا من اشوفك
ابتسم هناك علاقه عاطفيه عبر الاثير هواك
الله
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص اشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات